Antonio quantum computers is the wild
card it could be a game-changer it could
change the entire landscape of
artificial intelligence let me explain
at the present time our most advanced
robot some of which are built in Japan
and also at MIT have the collective
intelligence and wisdom of a cockroach a
mentally challenged cockroach a
lobotomized mentally challenged
cockroach these cockroaches take about
six hours to walk across the room the
entire room they see lines circles
squares triangles but they don't know
the fact that they're looking at chairs
desks tables people's lamps they see
better than us they don't know what they
are seeing also they hear better than us
but they don't understand what they are
hearing so we need a new architecture
and then in ten years
silicon power may run its course and the
silicon revolution may actually collapse
we're used to the fact that computers
double in power every 18 months that
can't go on forever Moore's law which is
the foundation of modern society may
eventually collapse in 10-15 years so we
physicists are looking for a replacement
a replacement molecular computers atomic
computers optical computers and quantum
computers quantum computers compute on
Adams not silicon they are as small as
you can get in terms of information
storage you can't get smaller than an
individual electron and they work by
looking at the spin and the orientation
of electrons if I put an electron in the
magnetic field it can spin up or it can
spin down that would be a 1 and that
would be a zero but in quantum mechanics
it could also be in between zero and one
so a bit one a bit zero can become a
qubit anything between zero and one not
to be fair the world's record for a
quantum computer calculation is
is Dada three times five is fifteen now
you probably already knew that three
times five is fifteen but remember that
calculation was done on five atoms so
here's a homework assignment for you
take five atoms and make a computation
three times five is fifteen and then you
begin to realize how difficult it is to
make quantum computers the problem is
interference cosmic rays a rumbling
truck outside your door small tremors in
the earth they create vibrations
sufficient to destroy the spin of the
electron and that's the problem that's
the reason why we don't have quantum
computers and remember if you can solve
this problem if you can create a quantum
computer that can fuse on individual
atoms and electrons you would be
heralded as the next Thomas Edison